hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
klassiker total lecker nämlich die
donauwelle ich kenne wirklich niemanden
der sie nicht liebt das besteht nämlich
aus einem schönen rührteig vanille und
schoko hat sich schon mal sehr gut an
außerdem kirchen einer pudding
buttercreme und einer schönen
schokoladenglasur und wir starten jetzt
zuallererst mit dem rührteig wir
benötigen mehr weiche butter eier
außerdem zucker backpulver ba kakao
vanille aroma oder vanille zucker etwas
milch und natürlich kirschen aus dem
glas für den rührteig benutze ich jetzt
die küchenmaschine das geht natürlich
auch mit dem handrührgerät dann braucht
es mal ein zwei minuten länger und wir
gehen wir zuallererst die weiche butter
rein die habe ich ungefähr drei stunden
vorher aus dem kühlschrank genommen
da gebe ich jetzt noch den kompletten
zucker hinzu und außerdem vanille aroma
und dann wird das ungefähr fünf minuten
lang richtig schön cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
so die butter ist es richtig schön
fluffig und da gehen wir jetzt die eier
hinzu und hier ist es besser wenn die
eier zimmertemperatur haben dann
verbindet sich das besser mit der mutter
und auch nur so lange bis sich das ganze
verbunden hat ich habe jetzt nur noch
mal die butter vom rand runter gekratzt
dass ich das auch gut miteinander
verbindet und als nächstes vermischen
wir backpulver und mail miteinander
cacau noch nicht das kommt erst später
zum einsatz
ich habe das noch ganz kurz mit dem
löffel und gibt ja schon mal zur hälfte
mit zur masse und lässt das richtig gut
unterwegs
[Musik]
und jetzt ruhig auf niedriger stufe
so ich habe jetzt zwei drittel der
mischung eingegeben und ihr merkt dass
der teig so ein bisschen fester wird an
der stelle geben wir die hälfte der
milch mit hinzu das sind zwei esslöffel
natürlich kommt auch immer auf die größe
der eier an die ihr verwendet und
nachdem ich sie milch untergerührt hat
gebe ich noch den rest der mimischen
pinsel
[Musik]
der rührteig ist jetzt sozusagen fertig
die donauwelle besteht ja zum einen teil
aus einem hellen teig und zum anderen
aus dem dunklen teig deswegen nehmen wir
uns jetzt etwas mehr als die hälfte von
diesem tag der jetzt gerade noch hell
ist und verteilen ihn auf unser
backblech ich habe jetzt noch einen bug
rahmen drum herum gegeben damit das
richtig schön glatt wird an den seiten
ich sag euch auch die maße das sind
ungefähr 38 x 28 cm und müsst ihr jetzt
nicht so genau sein und dann streiche
ich den teig richtig schön glatt
[Musik]
so der teil wäre erledigt und als
nächstes kümmern wir uns um den schoko
teig dafür ganz einfach wacker/mid zum
hellen teil geben außerdem noch die
milch denn der kakao der macht den teig
gibt so ein bisschen fest und die milch
hilft einfach dass er wieder ein
bisschen weicher wird ganz kurz nixon
und dann ist auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und unser schoko zeigt der wird jetzt
glatt auf dem vanille zeit verstrichen
[Musik]
so und nach denen ihr dann auch den
schokoladen tag richtig schön glatt
verstrichen habt geht es weiter mit den
kirschen und da gibt's ja dieses
typische muster in der donau welle wo
sich halt vanille und schoko teig
vermischen und viele machen den fehler
und fangen jetzt an mit einer gabel oder
mit einem schaftlich spielt da wild
herum zu stochern um dieses muster zu
erreichen aber bei der donau wird geht
das ganz anders
ihr müsst jetzt einfach die kirche
nehmen und auf den teig verteilen und
dann leicht eindrücken und so entsteht
eben auch dieses typische muster
[Musik]
die kirchen sind zur hälfte eingedrückt
und jetzt kommt das ganze in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für 20 minuten
anschließend lassen wir das vollständig
auskühlen
wir kümmern uns jetzt in der
zwischenzeit um die pudding buttercreme
und dafür benötigen wir folgende zutaten
einmal milch außerdem zucker
speisestärke vanille aroma oder wenn der
zucker und weiche butter die weiche
butter die brauchen wir erst später die
gebe ich jetzt an die seite und jetzt
kochen wir uns zuallererst ein
vanillepudding auf dafür gebe ich zwei
drittel der milch in meinem kopf schon
mal scheint sich aber noch nicht an ist
mache ich gleich erst und ein drittel
gebe ich in eine separate schüssel in
die schüssel mit der milch gebe ich
jetzt speisestärke vanille zucker oder
vanille aroma und zucker und dann wird
das gut miteinander verrührt
so die masse habe ich jetzt gut verrührt
und übrigens könnt ihr statt der
speisestärke und des vanillezucker auch
eine packung vanillepudding pulver
benutzen aber das geht auch so und so
ist es immer da also ich persönlich hab
immer speisestärke und vanille aroma
oder vanille zucker da und jetzt lasse
ich ganz einfach die milch in einem
kochtopf einmal aufkochen gibt dann die
mischung dazu dass es dann erneut
aufkochen so dass ich ein schöner
pudding bildet
[Musik]
und wenn ich normalerweise vanille
pudding kochen zu hause dann nehme ich
noch ein gelb mit dazu für die
konsistenz und auch für die farbe aber
hier brauchen wir das nächste der gleich
mit der butter vermischen
also könnt ihr euch das mit dem eigelb
sparen jetzt gebe ich das in eine
separate schüssel und werde das noch mal
an der oberfläche richtig gut mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken
[Musik]
und die frischhaltefolie verhindert dass
ich jetzt haut auf dem pudding bildet
und das müssen wir jetzt vollständig
auskühlen lassen am besten auf
zimmertemperatur darf nicht ganz kalt
sein vorbild weiterverarbeiten und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder so der
pudding ist vollständig abgekühlt und
jetzt werde ich das nochmal durch ein
feines haar sieben streichen damit auch
absolut keine klümpchen vorhanden sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und nicht dass ihr euch wundert dieser
pudding hat kleine vanille stückchen
denn ich habe das für den dreh schon
vorbereitet und ich mache mir da nichts
draus ob ich jetzt vanillezucker aber
nicht schoten oder vanille aroma nehmen
das könnte einfach selbst entscheiden
und bisher partie sah jetzt vanille
stückchen und sage ich euch den nächsten
schritt gehen wir die butter in die
küchenmaschine und schlagen die wir am
anfang beim rührteig auch ungefähr fünf
minuten man richtig schön hell cremig
[Musik]
so die butter ist es richtig schön hält
cremig und jetzt gebe ich immer es dafür
weise bei mittlerer geschwindigkeit
ungefähr im pudding mit dazu und bevor
ich es vergesse ihr könnt natürlich auch
euer handrührgerät verwenden also eine
küchenmaschine ist kein muss so unsere
pudding buttercreme ist fertig und wir
können sie auch sofort verstreichen nur
eben mein kuchen und dann geht es weiter
so der rührteig bei den kirchen ist
abgekühlt habe das mit einem küchentuch
einfach entdeckt und dann abkühlen
lassen und jetzt geben wir unsere
buttercreme da drauf und streichen das
auch wieder richtig schön glatt
[Musik]
und sobald ihr dann die oberfläche
richtig schön glatt gezogen habt gebt
ihr das ganze in den kühlschrank für
mindestens eine stunde damit wie die
glasur nachher schön darüber gießen
können aber in meinem fall also ich
mache heute nicht weiter wir sehen uns
morgen erst wieder durch das für die
ganze nacht in den kühlschrank ist könnt
ihr auch so handhaben falls sie am
gleichen tag keine zeit gehabt und am
nächsten tag weiter machen möchtet so
wir haben es jetzt den nächsten tag wie
gesagt eine stunde kühl zeit reicht auch
vollkommen aber wenn es mal nicht anders
geht dann macht ihr einfach am nächsten
tag weiter und ich habe hier die donau
weise schon auf meine arbeitsplatte
gelegt und hier sind noch die zutaten
für unsere glasur und 2000 das einmal
zeit später kuvertüre der sich ganz
langsam geschmolzen über dem wasserbad
und pflanzliches öl und das verrühren
jetzt gut miteinander verwies darauf
geben
[Musik]
achtet unbedingt darauf dass die
schokolade jetzt nicht mehr sehr heiß
ist damit die buttercreme es einfach
nicht schmilzt und jetzt wie gesagt
einfach drauf gießen und schön glatt
verstreichen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr die glasur darauf verteilt
habe fehlt nur noch unser typisches
wellenmuster das macht ihr mit so einer
gewählten teig karte und falls euer
kuchen jetzt ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommt so wie bei mir dann
lasst ihr die schokolade nur ungefähr
eine minute anziehen allerhöchstens aber
falls der kuchen zimmertemperatur hat
weil es im gleichen tag noch weiter
verarbeitet dann könnt ihr die
schokolade auch ungefähr vier bis fünf
minuten lang anziehen lassen dann merkt
einfach dass das wellenmuster viel
besser funktioniert
[Musik]
und sobald die glasur angetrocknet ist
könnt ihr eure donauwelle genießen und
glaubt mir leute die schmeckt so viel
besser als wir aus dem tiefkühler also
macht so unbedingt nach die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in die infobox ich freue
mich wie immer über eure tollen fotos
mit dem hashtag ekis kitchen auf
instagram ansonsten hinterlasst diesem
video gerne ein dummchen nach oben
abonniert fleißig aktiviert die glocke
dann bekommt ihr immer sofort mit wenn
wir was neues hoch laden und dann freue
ich mich bis zum nächsten mal auf dieses
kettchen tschüss
[Musik]